herzlich willkommen zu zdf heute live ab
morgen gilt sie die einrichtungs
bezogene impfpflicht sprich in
krankenhäusern und in der pflege müssen
die beschäftigten dem arbeitgeber
nachweisen dass sie gegen korona geimpft
sind oder von corona chinesen sind die
kritik daran ist massiv übermorgen berät
der bundestag über eine allgemeine
impfpflicht anfang april soll dann
fraktions unabhängig ohne fraktions
vorgaben darüber abgestimmt werden und
vielleicht jetzt mal das interessanteste
morgen geht es im bundestag um das neue
infektionsschutzgesetz sprich die für
den 20 märz geplanten lockerungen der
korona maßnahmen fünf tage also noch
dann soll es wenn es nach den ampel
plänen geht im grunde genommen so sein
dass die meisten corona maßnahmen
wegfallen
eine kluge idee angesichts der derzeit
extrem steigenden infektionszahlen über
das wegfallen der maßnahmen wird heftig
gestritten und wir wollen gemeinsam mit
ihnen heute darüber diskutieren und mit
diesen gästen zum einen der
grünen-politikerin und
bundestagsabgeordneten paul iby schotter
sie ist ärztin in sachsen sie ist für
eine verlängerung der maßnahmen und sie
ist für eine impfpflicht ab 50 heute
abend prima dass die zeit haben vielen
dank und wir reden mit wolfgang kubicki
dem stellvertretenden bundesvorsitzenden
der fdp erst gegen eine impfpflicht er
ist für das ende der corolla maßnahmen
und die ironie des schicksals will es
dass herr kubicki seit gestern abend
weiß dass der korona positiv ist
insofern ist der isolation kann bei der
bundestagsdebatte morgen gar nicht
teilnehmen hat aber den vater er hat
heute abend zeit für uns herr kubicki
schinken abend schön dass sie dabei sind
ja ein erster frage wie geht es ihnen
denn
ich bin infiziert aber nicht wirklich
krank ich hab gleich erkältungssymptome
aber von allen meinen freunden die das
gleiche schicksal widerfahren ist höre
ich dasselbe dauert zwei drei tagen ist
vorbei es gibt auch offensichtlich stehe
davon läuft aber ich fühle mich ganz gut
also dann ist das sozusagen der milde
verlauf aber sie sind muss man ja mal
fragen einfach doppelt geimpft gepustet
oder wie ist der status mit dem status
ist dieser wert gibt und gepustet und
zwar aus voller überzeugung ich habe
gesagt das war mein freedom day als mir
klar wurde ich muss nach der impfung vor
schweren verläufen keine sorge mehr
haben um sex bedeutet jetzt ist es so
dass rk ii meldet heute neue
rekordzahlen binnen 24 stunden 100 98
1888 neue fälle also sie gehören dazu
einer von denen zwei und mehr als
240.000 mehr als vor einer woche das
heißt es geht also wieder nach oben
außerdem kamen 283 todesfälle dazu das
ist ja doch auch eine heftige zahlt und
die sieben tage incidents hat jetzt
einen rekordwert erreicht von
1585 also neuer höchstwert und trotzdem
sollen am sonntag praktisch alle
schutzmaßnahmen fallen was geht ihnen da
durch den kopf stehen sie dazu ist das
wirklich richtig in dieser lage
ja weil wir erleben das potenzial um mit
einem anderen europäischen länder die
gleichen master vergessen werden wenn
die ehre haben eine deutlich höhere
instanz als deutschland und trotzdem
werden dort hat man in 20 märz nicht
mehr wehren maske neben der für die
person da sagte lange dem markt hat
lockerungsmaßnahmen begonnen war der
inzidenz von über 5.000 wir wissen dass
von den vielen infizierten die meisten
eben nicht mehr und lebenswerk kämpfen
gepustet mit weniger schweren verläufen
wir haben keinen zulauf auf den
stationen dankenswerterweise und
mitkommen bewahrt uns davor und auch mal
was meter die sie müssen ja wissen die
zahlen ausgewiesen werden bedeuten 70
bis 80 prozent derjenigen die dort als
corona patienten geführt werden sind in
wahrheit kein ich oder patienten sondern
deren einweisung kannst dann dazu
geführt dass sich positiv getestet
worden sind obwohl sie wegen anderer
krankheiten angewiesen wurden also es
gibt keine veranlassung mehr
ja auch dieser phase folgen und rechte
der armen da ist keine veränderung mehr
weil eine überlastung des
gesundheitssystems nicht weltweit an den
ausnahmen fest zweifel die übrigens
verwiesen ausgelaufen werden wir
schaffen hier neue maß an wissen wir
nichts getan wäre heute alles
ausgelaufen und wir sorgen jetzt dafür
dass einige maßnahmen noch weitergeführt
werden das waren dann wendet ihr ein
hotspot haben wenn wir einen
funktionstüchtigen haben lokal das
besonders betroffen werden will ist dass
die länder dann auch einfach weitergehen
würde das ist alles was notwendig ist
ist auch angemessen bereits gesehen dann
greift das ist einfach mal auf und
fragen sie frau wirklich lotter die da
ein bisschen anderer meinung sind hat
herr kubicki denn nicht recht die
politik hat gesagt wenn die lage es
erlaubt so war es eben vor wochen und
monaten die lage es erlaubt zu lockern
dann sollte man das tun und das
kriterium hat man nun gesagt nicht mehr
die infektionszahlen sondern eben die
lage auf den intensivstationen wenn man
sich das also leisten kann dann muss man
locker und jetzt soll gelockert werden
die meisten maßnahmen sollen wegfallen
warum denn eigentlich nicht
ich bin jetzt ich kann alle
nachvollziehen und dann gehört ein stück
weit auch herr kubicki dazu die sagen
das so vielen monaten von wirklich
harten beschränkungen brauchen wir jetzt
eine öffnung perspektive haben wir jetzt
können auch nie etwas dagegen gehabt wir
hätten uns schon gewünscht dass es eine
bessere ausbalancierung gibt zwischen
den maßnahmen die man beibehält und den
eröffnungsfestakt leben die mannschaft
wenn sie mich fragen ich kann halt nicht
jeder gruppe ausschließlich vorstand
sondern aus sachsen das habe ich auch
schon öfter betont dass es einfach auch
eine ganz andere situation bei uns ist
haben zum beispiel eine viel niedrigere
importe und wenn ich mir dann anschauen
dass wir auch jetzt ab sofort in vielen
regionen auch die massen pflicht in
vielen bereichen verzichten sollen also
eine möglichkeit mit einem relativ
geringen eingriff in die persönlichen
freiheiten von menschen eine relativ
große wirkung zu erzielen was die das
verhindern von infektionen angeht dann
hätte ich mir da eine andere balance auf
jeden fall gewünscht ich kann aber ich
bin durchaus auch der meinung dass wir
jetzt zum sommer hin natürlich erst mal
davon ausgehen können dass ist
wahrscheinlich nicht nur situationen die
im letzten winter jetzt gibt aber ich
glaube wir müssen insbesondere mit blick
auf den herbst schauen dass wir dann
nicht zum dritten mal in einen herbst
gehen und uns vorbereitet sind das ist
ganz wichtig und wir erleben auch jetzt
dass wir sehr viele menschen gerade
haben die neu nach deutschland kommen
insbesondere aus der ukraine
neben putin der ukraine es sehr sehr
schlecht und wenn man auf der flucht ist
es so was die massen pflicht und
abstandsregel vielleicht auch nicht das
wichtigste und insbesondere auch wenn
uns das anschauen sollten wir glaube ich
sehr vorsichtig weiterhin bleiben
insbesondere auch wenn wir darüber
nachdenken dass diese ganzen menschen ja
zusätzlich im land sind und potenziell
im herbst zum beispiel auch von diesem
gesundheitssystem mit versorgt werden
müssen also da hört man ganz klar dass
sie zu den warnenden stimmen gehören und
insofern wird es ganz interessant sein
gemeinsam jetzt mit ihnen weiter zu
diskutieren wir wollen uns aber einfach
noch einmal gemeinsam anschauen was dort
morgen im bundestag besprochen wird eben
das neue
infektionsschutzgesetz was hat es ganz
genau damit aus sicht ein kurze
zusammenfassung
die korona zahlen steigen und zwar auf
rekordniveau gleichzeitig fallen ab
sonntag fast alle bundesweiten corona
maßnahmen weg geht es nach den
lockerungs plänen der ampel koalition
nach
einem entwurf der regierung soll am 20
märz noch der sogenannte basisschutz
gelten darüber wird ab morgen im
bundestag diskutiert masken pflicht also
nur noch in pflegeheimen kliniken und im
öffentlichen nah und fernverkehr
testpflicht nur in einrichtungen mit
besonders gefährdeten personen
verschlechtert sich die korona lage
lokal können dann regelungen für hot
spots greifen dazu gehören die massen
pflichten innenraumhygiene konzepte und
zugangsbeschränkungen darüber
entscheidet dann jedes bundesland selbst
den neuen gesetzesentwurf gibt es weil
er 19 märz das bisherige
infektionsschutzgesetz ausläuft
das heißt das sinnvollste und einfachste
wäre es dieses verfallsdatum nach hinten
zu verschieben 20 der juli zum beispiel
in die aktuelle gesetzeslage sieht nur
vor dass die länder verschiedene
möglichkeiten haben verschiedene
optionen haben auf schwierige corona
situation zu reagieren wieso den ländern
diese möglichkeiten dem diese option
nehmen denn möglichkeiten optionen
schränken ja niemanden ein es gibt also
gar keinen sachlichen grund die
gesetzeslage so wie sie ist zu ändern
die länder zu beschränken und auch alle
bürger zu verwirren völlig unnötig am
freitag sollen bundestag und bundesrat
der novelle des infektionsschutzgesetzes
zustimmen schon jetzt haben mehr der
landesregierung aber angekündigt
weiterhin an maßnahmen festhalten zu
wollen die über den basisschutz
hinausgehen
tja herr kubicki also und sarah attacke
unser rechtsexpertin sagt völlig unnötig
die hälfte der befragten das zdf
politbarometer hatte am 11 märz gefragt
wie sie denn zu dem wegfallen der korona
maßnahmen stehen da hat die hälfte der
befragten gesagt ja es richtig aber im
grunde um die andere hälfte 47 prozent
haben gesagt dass finden sie nicht
richtig und in den vergangenen tagen
sind die warnenden stimmen mehr geworden
ich habe ja eben die zahlen nochmal
zusammengefasst die das rk ii meldet 283
tote die mit krone an cholera gestorben
sind das ist ja auch jeden tag eine zahl
da bleiben sie dabei man kann trotzdem
sozusagen grünes licht geben und es
genauso wie in dänemark und anderen
ländern machen ja zunächst einmal
herzlich vortag gesehen aber wie das
leben so ist entscheidung aus der
deutsche bundestag das heißt jeder
eigene toilette muss das licht ausmachen
und ich kann nur sagen dass die
koalitionsfraktionen sich heute auf
einen gesetzentwurf geeinigt haben der
online wert im deutschen bundestag
finden wird die den mehrheits und stärke
und nach kommt weitgehend sondern x ite
zurückzukehren noch einmal wir räumen
den ländern ja alles unter ein von
bestimmten maßnahmen gebraucht zumal es
irgendwie nicht richtig das macht
pflicht auf jeden fall weiter besteht
also müssen länder beschließen das
einzige was der bund macht ist eine
masse pflicht im fernverkehr und in den
flugzeugen weil er seine zuständigkeit
ist den rest müssen die länder im
zweifel nach eigener überzeugung selbst
beschließen weil sie unterschiedliche
gegebenheiten haben sachsen anders als
in schleswig holstein und dass die
länder wissen 2 april findet übrigens
regung gebrauch machen ist auch
gesetzlich notwendig denn sie werden
sonst eine regelungslücke wo jetzt die
alle maßnahmen wegfallen würden jetzt so
kann herren länder die möglichkeit ihrer
verordnungen bis zum 2 april anzupassen
und das wird auch geschehen wir müssen
aus der angst basierten corona politik
heraus sondern vernünftige politik wir
können nicht das einzige land in europa
sein was wieder glaubt es besser zu
wissen dass alle anderen noch einmal
voll an turnierende auch wenn sie denn
es aktuell von 2.500 und lockern alles
österreich und schweiz deutlich höher
als die dänen als begonnen haben zu
öffnen
über 5000 gehabt die inzidenz zahlen
selbst sagen ja nichts mehr aus denn
auch ich wusste wenn jetzt infektion
soll obwohl
ich heute hat dann muss man sie eben
fragen weil sie ja dann doch als grüne
kritik daran üben und sagen da geht die
in die liberalen ein bisschen zu weit
greifen das auf was er kubicki sagt aber
auch vor allen dingen einen gedanken den
die politiker immer gesagt hat wenn der
staat in freiheitsrechte eben eingreift
dann muss er das ja immer begründen und
ist nicht mit omikron sozusagen die
begründung weggefallen weil es eben
weniger schwere verläufe gibt also nicht
so wie vor anderthalb jahren mit delta
und so weiter
ich habe auch wenn man sich omikron
anschaut natürlich verändert dass ein
stück weit die faktenlage aber es drehte
faktenlage hat nicht um 180 grad um und
ich bin total happy
wenn er sagt wir dürfen nicht jetzt
wirklich die maximal ssten maßnahmen auf
teufel komm raus über monate hinweg
weiter ziehen aber was er eben auch
nicht machen dürfen ist zum dritten mal
in folge diese diesen jojo-effekt
generieren mit corona maßnahmen dass wir
dann wenn wir das gefühl haben es wird
ein bisschen besser alle maßnahmen mit
einmal einen krassen und dann die umso
größere welle nach hinten raus haben und
dass wir jetzt wieder doppelt und
dreifach wieder doppelt und dreifach
freiheitseinschränkende maßnahmen
einführen müssen das war so zumindest in
den letzten jahren und niemand weiß im
moment wirklich seriös wie der herbst
aussehen wird weil das einfach von
unglaublich vielen verschiedenen
faktoren abhängt das wird davon abhängen
welche variante ist dann hat es wird
davon abhängen wie viele menschen dann
geimpft sind und vielen anderen faktoren
mehr und in dieser situation jetzt
wieder in die vollen zu gehen und
wirklich nur die minimalsten maßnahmen
aufrecht zu erhalten wie gesagt da
hätten sich manche oder und viele auch
aus meiner parteien in anderen weg
gewünscht weil wir einfach natürlich
auch die anderen nachbarländer sehen
aber die haben zum beispiel kubik sind
wir auch genau zum beispiel eine viel
höhere impfquote und wir haben
eigentlich das ist unzutreffend
probierte dass viele menschen auch in
deutschland auch im hohen alter die
immer noch nicht geimpft sind und das
ist einfach eine gefahr die man nicht
wie man nicht wegdiskutieren
herr kubicki man kann einfach mal die
zahlen jetzt neben dänemark da sind
81,6 prozent ja gerade frisch
nachgeguckt der aktuelle stand vom 15
märz also heute 81,6 prozent sind
doppelt 62 prozent sind gepustet bei uns
ist die zahl 76 prozent sind doppelt und
58 prozent gebucht hat also sind wir
etwas hinterher sie hat wie sie kurz
korrigieren bevor falsche zahl den
umlauf sind bei den menschen bei uns wie
bei 18 18 bis 1 endlichkeit wir eine
impfquote von über 85 prozent und sie
müssen mal gucken was sie zählen die
gesamtbevölkerung
die erwachsene bevölkerung das ja gerade
das was wir tun wir vergleichen im
gehirn weil der erwachsene völkers bei
der wirkung ab 18 jahren haben wir die
ins boot von 185 prozent was soll da
noch oben drauf gepackt werden also
gehen sie hin und sagen dann sind wir
sogar besser als die dänen und sie ja
kubicki würden sagen wahrscheinlich auch
in dänemark den niederlanden und
großbritannien wird es einen herbst
geben aber trotzdem ist das kein grund
weil ein herbst auf und zu kommt jetzt
nicht zu lockern wie sehen sie das
glaube ich glaube schon dass wir uns
auch der herbst vorbereiten müssen in
den berlins kanal mit jochen sie
komplett verpufft ist mal wieder zum
leben erwecken wir nehmen wir die
menschen doch an alten masten pflicht
wenn ihr abgestraft wird heißt nicht
dass keine was getragen sollte ich würde
immer empfehlen beispielsweise wenn ich
in menschenansammlungen kommen eine
maske zu tragen weil ich das auch im
winter bewährt richtigen griffe mehr
aber direkt in der pflicht da ist nicht
das machst einen tage verboten wird er
etwa an der pflicht es nicht dass
menschen nicht vernünftig verhalten
können das ist ja mal meine mandantin
petitum tragen wir den menschen mehr zu
umgehen die sache zu rücken hier
eigenverantwortung würde sinnvolle
kampagne die menschen überzeugen statt
die zugänge
was sagen sie frau berta ich meine
eigene verantwortung das sagt herr
kubicki auch ihre kollegin christine
aschenberg-dugnus eigenverantwortung
eigenverantwortung die sollte man den
menschen doch überlassen auf der anderen
seite beim impfen hat es mit appellen ab
allen appellen und handelt doch
verantwortlich denkt an andere nicht so
ganz geklappt und es gibt am ende auch
eine gurtpflicht mit bußgeld etc man
könnte auch sagen eigenverantwortlich
müsste jeder den gurt anlegen ich weiß
nicht ob ich oder wie sehen sie dieses
argument von herrn
ich finde erst mal das beispiel mit der
kürzlich ein bisschen schwierig weil ich
finde da gibt's schon sehr sehr große
unterschiede im vergleich zur pflicht
aber ja ich würde tatsächlich ein stück
weit wieder sprechen das ist natürlich
so dass wenn pflichten teilen und das
mag auch in unterschiedlichen regionen
deutschlands unterschiedlich sein aber
das ist ein extrem schweres und noch
dieser maßnahmen durchzusetzen und das
daneben auch die doch machte tragen
könnten dass das halt im zweifelsfall
dann eben nicht mehr passiert und es ist
nicht so dass wir jetzt noch völlig
abstrakt über das für und wider von
massen pflichten sprechen müssten wären
es einfach zwei über zwei jahre
erfahrung damit welche maßnahmen in
deutschland welche effekte generieren
und wir wissen einfach dass die massen
pflichten in verschiedenen settings von
innenraum immer extrem wichtig waren
dafür das infektionsgeschehen wieder
einzufangen und ich sage nicht ich hatte
ja gar nicht hier guck mir ganz gut
fertig ich sage ja gar nicht dass sie
jetzt machst unterrichten würde ich in
allen settings weiter bräuchten aber ich
möchte einfach zu bedenken geben dass
sie einmal sehr viele maßnahmen
auslaufen lassen und dass wenn ich mir
das ganze die ganze breite des
instrumentenkasten sun denkbaren
maßnahmen anschaut die maßen pflicht
nach die ist in der geringsten
freiheitseinschränkung verbunden ist und
auf der anderen seite einfach sehr sehr
große effekte generieren kann das den
schutz vor infekten angeht dann wollen
wir genau dazu ganz kurz bevor wir
weiter darüber reden einfach auch mal
die meinung einer virologen wir hören
gleich noch einen anderen hören nämlich
die virologin frau professor ulrike
protzer haben wir gefragt und das ist
ihre meinung dazu ich glaube die
restriktionen kann man auslaufen lassen
aber diese relativ einfache und wirksame
maßnahme der masken pflicht um die zu
schützen die sich anders nicht schützen
können die gefährdet sind in bereichen
wo sie einfach hinein müssen die halte
ich notwendig für aufrecht zu erhalten
jacobi da deckt sich also ein bisschen
die meinung von der virologe mit der von
vp schotter warum dieses simple ja und
gar nicht mal so lästige instrument aus
der hand geben
ja es mag sein aber ich habe genauso wie
ich hatte
mit geologen gesprochen hat auch mit die
regierung gesprochen mit herz standards
beispielsweise oder eine strecke auf der
rosa rosen spiel der ist mitglied des
expertenrats besteht deutschland hat
heute einfach nicht erklärt dass diese
maßnahmen können also da gibt es
unterschiedliche auffassungen
entscheiden muss den schluss der
deutsche bundestag ich kann doch mal
wiederholen wir haben uns heute in den
koalitionsfraktionen auf eine lösung
verständigt die wird jetzt auch
umgesetzt und alles weitere will mir
anschließend sehen da wird aber nicht
mehr sehr viel geändert werden die
waffen der nächsten zwei drei tage und
das ist eben das problem wir haben
unterschiedliche auffassungen
dieser auffassung ein bisschen
irgendwann zu einer gemeinsamen lösung
führen diese jetzt gefunden haben
deshalb werden wir das umsetzen den
ländern wie gesagt die möglichkeit geben
in bestimmten bereichen masken und tests
pflichten anzuordnen beispielsweise
testberichten auch in kitas was bisher
nicht vorgesehen war und maske pflichten
auch beispielsweise
obdachlosenunterkünften und weiteren
gemeinschaftsunterkünfte was bisher
nicht vorgesehen war also dort wo es
darauf ankommt von dem öpnv und dann
schauen wir doch mal was passieren wird
ich glaube nicht dass das ein ganz
anderes gemacht werden ich glaube dass
die frau pia das anders glaubt dass wir
nicht nur ein vernünftiger sommer haben
werden sondern dass wir uns jetzt
vernünftiger weise darauf vorbereiten
sollen mit einer möglichen welle im
herbst oder winter verwirklicht zu
werden und das muss andere maßnahmen
beinhalten dass er gegenwärtig
diskutieren dann wollen wir einfach es
ist ein zufall den von ihnen zitierten
virologe professor jonas
schmidt-chanasit hören den haben wir
nämlich auch kurz vor der sendung
gefragt und das ist das was er zu dem
thema gesagt hat ist ja für sie beide
interessant
an ihm nicht vorbei aber man muss sich
natürlich überlegen ob man diese
verpflichtenden bevölkerungsweiten
maßnahmen weiter aufrechterhält in allen
anderen europäischen ländern wird das
nicht gemacht sondern man schaut ihnen
die bereiche die besonders gefährdet
sind so wie man das in deutschland eben
auch plant altenpflegeheime war man muss
sich natürlich überlegen ob man auch die
anderen gesundheitsrisiken die natürlich
weiterhin bestehen entsprechend gut
abfedern kann ob das noch
verhältnismäßig ist oder ob es ihrem
weiterhin gerechtfertigt es sich alleine
oder sehr stark auf saas kauf zwei zu
konzentrieren und diese frage ist ja
meine sachen zu dem neuen
infektionsschutzgesetz so beantwortet
dass man sich jetzt eben auf die
besonders gefährdeten bereiche
konzentrieren will
tja da hat er da nicht recht andere
länder machen das hier ein bisschen und
sagen jetzt müssen wir das langsam mal
wieder etwas entspannter sehen und seen
omikron etc doch wie eben andere
krankheiten auch und konzentrieren uns
nicht nur darauf uns bringen eben damit
auch wieder normalität zurück hat ja
schon dass es da nicht doch recht
mit der position weg als ich gerade
geschildert hat habe ich ja gar keinen
raum geben also ich habe ganz am anfang
gesagt wir finden uns auch unglaublich
wichtig dass man jetzt öffnungs
perspektiven schafft es geht ja nicht so
sehr um die frage schaffen jetzt
öffnungs perspektiven oder nicht
öffnungs perspektiven wollen wir alle
schaffen es geht um die frage der
konkreten ausgestaltung und die frage in
welchen bereichen noch massen pflichten
gelten sollen und welche möglichkeiten
unsere bundesländer noch haben sollen
dann gegebenenfalls nochmal stärkeren
tiefgreifende maßnahmen zu machen das
ist der ganze unterschied der ist jetzt
nicht so wahnsinnig groß wie er zum
beispiel in anderen phasen der pandemie
teilweise war zwischen vertretern von
gold und anderen
gruppen das ist jetzt wirklich im
vergleich zu früheren
auseinandersetzungen der pandemie ein
vergleichsweise kleiner präsent auch
wenn er noch groß genug ist ja trotzdem
noch mal die frage an sie beide das ist
ja ein dezenz innerhalb einer regierung
innerhalb einer koalition
da sagen die liberalen das müssen wir
jetzt unbedingt durchziehen und da gibt
es bauchschmerzen ein bisschen wahr herr
mützenich bei den grünen auch wie soll
denn eigentlich der wähler der normale
bürger dieses hü und hott innerhalb
einer regierungskoalition verstehen
wir haben in corona zeiten und corona
politik war immer strittig und da war es
auch nie so dass das selbst innerhalb
von parteien wirklich alle einer meinung
gewesen wären wir haben jetzt wirklich
über 24 monate sehr sehr harte
politische debatte hin zu den
verschiedensten corona fragen hinter uns
insbesondere wenn wir auf die ganzen
fragen schule zu schule auf die frage
wie wir die impfungen die importe
erhöhen können das dann immer hoch
emotionale debatten und das ist kein
höhe und hotmail nach sondern das ist
einfach das ringen um die beste lösung
das jetzt nicht aufhört das aber meiner
meinung nach im vergleich zu früheren
phasen der pfanne mir jetzt schon
deutlich zielführender läuft war der auf
einfach bei vielen punkten inzwischen
auch als politische entscheider in mehr
bisschen als noch vor zwei jahren
also ich stimme aus ich stelle
ausdrücklich sagen wenn ich das sagen
darf weil selbstverständlich wie aus
unterschiedlichen parteien das
natürliche position bekommen wir haben
uns heute geeinigt das ist der sinn von
demokratischer gestaltung das seien
unterschiedliche auffassungen zueinander
bringt und wie einer koalition sich auf
eine gemeinsame lösung verständigt das
ist heute geschehen und ihr seid es ist
kein keinen sinn dieser streit war ein
streit innerhalb der ampel sondern es
ist ein ringen um die beste lösung und
das ergebnis wurde immer ein kompromiss
sei hinter die herangehensweisen ich
kann mich noch irgendwie von kinder- und
jugendärztin bestimmt worden noch im
letzten winter als die gesagt hat die
macht wirklich so muss offen sagen dass
ich mir alle gesagt dass die wachen
kinder damit alle die jetzt eigenen
kinder lieben gott sei dank fällt das
denken ich hätte gesagt er dokumentiert
da gab es 55 lassen wo es keine
möglichkeit von 76 lassen wo es wasser
richtig gas und intelligenz gruppen
identisch das hat darauf hingedeutet
dass auch mit dem was täglich schulen
auf das infektionsgeschehen selbst gar
keinen einfluss hatte also noch einmal
wir müssen alle faktoren berücksichtigen
und freue mich ja nicht gleich wasser
entfernt wir können frei agieren sollte
es zu einer ausbruchs lösungen kombi wir
alle nicht wollen und wie wir auch
verhindern wollen der bundestag kann er
von wenigen tagen alle machen wird wenn
jetzt ergreifen das ist mir jetzt nicht
aufs tor abschliessen das machen wir
dann längst auch ankommt und ich finde
die menschen müssen das gefühl haben sie
werden ordentlich regiert in anderen
ländern europas auf kommen wir zu den
gefühlen der menschen wir haben einige
kommentare auch positiv schreibt über
facebook einfach mal über ihre sorgen
die klinik ist noch voll genug und kein
personal wenn alle maßnahmen wegfallen
habe ich angst wie wir die leute noch
versorgen sollen wir kriechen ja jetzt
schon auf dem zahnfleisch einfach mal
eine stimme aus einer klinik und ep 2000
schreibt über youtube frage an herrn
kubicki werden lockerungen jetzt nicht
wieder in einigen wochen zum verhängnis
aufgrund punkt punkt christian lindner
hat letztes jahr beim aufkommen der
alpha variante auch schon für
lockerungen geworben also da so eine
gewisse angst dass ja alles noch dollar
werden könnte diese incident zahlen die
wir jetzt haben und jetzt kommt
sozusagen jemand den sie ja eigentlich
vertreten nämlich die wirtschaft der
bundesverband der deutschen industrie
sagt heute das ist der chef siegfried
russwurm eine großzügige lockerung ist
angesichts neuer rekordwerte bei den
infektionszahlen schwer zu verantworten
und ich habe den eindruck so ein
bisschen klingt damit schwingt damit bei
der kritik dass vielleicht die
wirtschaft angst hat das ist dann nicht
jetzt zu ganz schweren massiven fällen
kommt und alle mitarbeiter in der auf
der intensivstation landen aber das ist
dann noch mehr kranke gibt als was wir
überall in allen betrieben jetzt schon
beobachten und dass das vielleicht diese
angst nicht ganz unbegründet ist das
zeigt ein kurzer beitrag der dieser
frage nachgeht
professor torsten lehr von der uni
saarland erstellt seit beginn der
pandemie prognosemodelle zum
infektionsgeschehen den anstieg der
zahlen hat er damit vorhergesagt eine
überlastung der intensivstation scheint
ihm bei omi korn nicht wahrscheinlich er
sieht eine ganz andere gefahr die
problematik dabei ist natürlich dass wir
dann auch sehr viele aktive fälle haben
das heißt sehr viele menschen die mit
der erkrankung dann in quarantäne gehen
müssen um dort dann natürlich dann auch
der gesellschaft nicht mehr als
arbeitende bevölkerung zur verfügung
stehen das sind zurzeit etwa zwei
millionen schon ohne öffnungs schritte
könnte sich diese zahl mehr als
verdoppeln wir das eigentlich im fall
sogar schon hier zu knapp fünf millionen
leuten kommen die eben zu hause sind und
dort letztendlich da nicht der arbeit
zugänglich das wären etwa zehn prozent
der arbeitenden und eine öffnung könnte
die situation noch einmal verschärfen
doch die deutschen wollen raus aus der
pandemie
jacobi gekommen vielleicht selten vor
aber die wirtschaft will etwas was sie
nicht wollen die wirtschaftliche nämlich
auf keinen fall mehr kranke zu hause
haben
zunächst einmal ist präsident des bde
mde die wirtschaft als
interessenvertreter der deutschen
industrie wir haben sehr viel
mittelständische unternehmen die ganz
andere überlegungen haben und ich finde
diese logik die jagd alle sozusagen
propagiert wird sehr interessant zu
wissen ich bin jurist und denke dass er
intensiver nach da ich ja als gebuchter
und geimpfter mich auch infiziert haben
auch in keinen der uns steht die frage
der was ich gar keine rolle dann auch
die hosen und und
genießen dann können sich infizieren
müssen dann die garantie dass müssen uns
von meist der frage bringen was gerade
in spanien sehr der sieht diskutiert
wird ob man die quarantänezeit nicht
verkürzen müsste wenn man weiß dass man
dem fuß hatten deutlich weniger intensiv
für infektions gefahren ausgehen aber
das geht allen die effektive infizieren
können weil wir maske sagen alles was
momentan passiert in dem residenz was
zählt man dem aktuellen geschrieben was
wir haben was auslaufen soll ersetzt
werden soll insofern ist es kein beleg
dafür dass alle weitergehende öffnung zu
schlechteren und gravierenderen zahlen
führen würde noch einmal wir haben uns
jetzt entschieden dass umzusetzen das
werden wir tun sollte es bestand
situation kommen die ich nahezu
ausschließt die fast alle die ich kenne
ausschließen wird der deutsche bundestag
reagieren aber noch einmal mit angst
basierte politik hier kommen wir nicht
weiter müssen den leuten erklären wie
sie
sagen sie haben sich jetzt in der ampel
geeinigt knirschen vielleicht aber der
punkt ist der dass das neue
infektionsschutzgesetz noch gar nicht
morgen finde es ja statt debattiert ist
am freitag soll es verabschiedet werden
und vorher schon ist klar dass die
länder ja dann doch wieder etwas anderes
machen bayern sagt
man lässt 2g und 3g masken pflicht auch
in schulen oder handel bis zum 24 also
nutzt schon sozusagen zu sagen man
verschiebt das ganze diese
übergangsfrist thüringen sachsen
brandenburg sagen das machen wir auch
berlin und saarland wollen die maßnahmen
des 31 beibehalten häufig heute ist das
wie in der vergangenheit wo eine groko
dinge entschieden hat und die länder
sagen ja wir machen es ja doch ein
bisschen anders
denn dass die länder hier selbst muss
entscheiden weil die länder einfach auch
die situation bei sich vor uns sehr gut
kennen und weil wir auch wissen dass
auch gerade viele ministerpräsidenten in
unserem land willkommen bei corona oft
vor wichtiger waren als manche akteure
auf der bundesebene ich finde es gut
dass die länder das jetzt entscheiden
können das ja auch die übergangsfrist zu
nutzen und ich finde das ist auch ein
klares politisches signal dass sehr
viele bundesländer der tatsächlich im
moment lieber eine spur zu vorsichtig
sein wollen als eine spur zu vorschnell
unglaublich viele dieser 16 bundesländer
in den letzten zwei jahren schlechte
erfahrungen damit gemacht haben zu
schnell zu lockern und den fehler möchte
man und das kann ich sehr gut
nachvollziehen nicht nochmal machen
vielleicht damit noch kurz einwirken
dass die länder dafür eigentlich
zwischen dies sind darunter wohin der
pandemie situation 2020 die
zuständigkeit in teilbereichen der an
sich gezogen es war immer die länder
zuständig für die effektive bekämpfung
und jetzt haben wir das zurückgegeben an
die länder und auch an die
landesparlamente denn die maßnahmen und
man es eben entschieden werden müssen
müssen durch die dortige parlamente und
da gehört sie auch hin also von der
verfassungsmäßigen aufzahlung her ist
die organspende von den ländern und die
müssen jetzt sind ihre parlamente und
ich glaube das der richtige weg dann
einfach nur eine frage an sie beide das
nutzen wir sofort andreas hartmann frage
nämlich über facebook gibt es in der
ampel sie sind beide vertreter der ampel
eigentlich irgendwelche planungen um die
klinischen kapazitäten zu steigern das
ist ja nun eine sache die in der
vergangenheit als die kliniken wirklich
voll waren was er doch angemahnt wurde
jetzt heißt es wieder die
intensivstationen sind gar nicht so sehr
belegt aber dann wieder das krankenhaus
mehr gibt es denn da irgendwelche
planungen dass man dann vielleicht
andreas hat man eben sagen kann na ja
man hat aus den erfahrungen der letzten
monate gelernt vw schotter
verkehr weil es hat am anfang der partie
dazu geführt dass wir unglaublich viel
geld für beatmungsgeräte und neue betten
ausgegeben haben die dann auf dem flur
standen weil es überhaupt niemanden gab
der menschen in diesen städten hätte
pflegen können und was wir säen über die
gesamte dauer der pandemie ist dass wir
kontinuierlich personal verlieren
deshalb die debatte wie können wir die
kapazitäten im gesundheitswesen
ausweiten ist auf der einen seite schon
deswegen mit völlig ad absurdum geführt
weil wir gerade eher kapazitäten
verlieren als sie aufbauen und ich
glaube um den beruf im gesundheitswesen
wieder attraktiv zu machen müssen wir
halt unter anderem diese pandemie
beenden weil die natürlich unglaublich
großen einfluss hat darauf dass die
arbeitsbedingung zurzeit noch
anstrengender und schwieriger sind als
ohnehin schon weil zum beispiel auch
immer viele kollegen krank werden und
auf der anderen seite ist es aber auch
falsch zu denken dass man eine pandemie
mit ausreichend vielen krankenhausbetten
ohne einschränkungen für die gesamte
bevölkerung bewältigen kann man wird nie
so viele krankenhausbetten haben dass
man einer unbegrenzten pandemie
standhalten kann dann müsste jeder von
uns im gesundheitswesen arbeiten und es
würde in diesem land nicht viel sonst
passieren es ist einfach nicht die
möglichkeit pandemien bekämpft man nicht
mit krankenhausbetten oder arztpraxen
panin bekämpft man mit impfungen und mit
bevölkerungsschutz maßnahmen die
infektionen verhindern und damit dass
meine starke weltgesundheitsorganisation
hatte die pandemie frühen erkennen kann
dann fragen wir zum abschluss herrn
kubicki noch weil diese frage ja eben im
raum steht und sie vielleicht den
engeren draht noch zu herrn lindner dem
finanzminister haben wie sie das ganze
sehen ob eben die kliniken doch besser
ausgestattet werden ob der job
attraktiver gemacht wird durch bessere
bezahlung sind ja alles sachen die in
zweieinhalb jahren pandemie was drei
jahren pandemie in zwei jahren die
pandemie ja eben besprochen worden sind
also in der tat gebe ich zu dass die
ampel jetzt das lösen muss was in 16
jahren sich auch krankenhausbereich
angehäuft hat das glück heute auf morgen
geht wir brauchen definitiv mehr
personal gebraucht besser bezahltes
personal gerade im pflegerischen bereich
wir brauchen natürlich andere struktur
der krankenhausfinanzierung ist das ein
beispiel wie man bis august des jahres
2020 wir krankenhäuser dafür dass er
sich aufgebaut hat nun 560 euro pro tag
also geplatzt sehr viele intensivbetten
und als die finanzierung umgestellt
wurde bei peter südbeck nämlich belegt
sind sehr teuer sind und dann nicht
refinanziert werden können als die
finanzierung gestellt wurde bono
logischerweise wieder abgebaut also wir
müssen schon mal schauen dass wir
vernünftig eine finanzierung hinbekommen
für die tätigen das uns nicht nur
bundestags und auch ländersache und wenn
wir uns darauf vorbereiten wollen die
künftigen herausforderungen wie frau ich
habe das richtigerweise das auch dann
fertig zu werden dann brauchen wir
bevölkerungsschutz über den c wir
brauchen aber eine völlig andere
krankenhausstruktur allgegenwärtig
dann danke ich ihnen ganz herzlich
freut sich otto wird es morgen bei der
bundestagssitzung mit sicherheit dabei
sein wenn es um das neue
infektionsschutzgesetz gibt geht herr
kubicki kann das leider nicht weil eine
isolation ist wir wünschen aber gute
genesung sie werden das genauso genauso
verfolgen und ich denke wir werden dann
gemeinsam auch noch mal über weitere
dinge sprechen denn wir haben ja noch
andere themen die im allgemeine
impfpflicht et cetera was dann im april
ansteht für den heutigen tag ganz
herzlichen dank gute genesung vielen
dank an sie frau bei cotta in dohna
wiedersehen
und an sie liebe userinnen und user ein
großes dankeschön für ihr interesse die
fragen die wir gemeinsam diskutiert
haben und vielen dank für ihr interesse
tschüss und auf wiedersehen